là où ça bouge revisitons l'histoire
tout d'abord de napoléon puis devront
pour la restauration des statues du
château de l eau c b au conservatoire de
caen pour un diot de prestige en
représentation ce soir hugues leclerc et
daniel mesguich interprète la mort de
l'aigle napoléon de la gloire à l'exil
d'après les mémoires de l'empereur
recueillis à sainte hélène
la qualité d'italiens a sûrement
contribué à déterminer le pape à me
couronnées qui s'est jusqu'à quel point
il était flatté de voir une famille qui
avait toujours joué un rôle à rome qui
depuis un temps immémorial avait eu
quelques monseigneur bo n'a pas à son
service
placé sur le premier tron de l'europe et
lui donner des lois va surgir de la
lecture des textes et des scènes qu'on
imagine puisque c'est très narratif on
imagine napoléon à sainte-hélène dans
son sa chambre à coucher sa salle de
billard et ainsi de suite
donc de là la dramaturge et la musique
s'impose est aussi la couleur
il ya un bonheur pour moi ha ha ha ha ha
entendre à m'entendre au milieu de ce
que j'entends et non pas simplement à
émettre quelque chose oui et puis je
pense qu est la véritable musique quand
on parle de la musique des mots ce n'est
pas juste une posture une métaphore
c'est une réalité c'est à dire que
un comédien
qui maîtrise l'art de l'addiction est
quelqu'un qui maîtrise le rythme qu'ils
maîtrisent l'intonation qui va maîtriser
là le silence
les réellement aimé joséphine mais je ne
l'estimait pas elle était trop menteuse
mais elle avait un je ne sais quoi qui
plaisait c'était une vraie femme elle
avait le plus joli petit cul qui fut
possible c'est paris match avant l'heure
autre motif ou plus c'est vous à vous on
vous dit quelque chose
vous ne devriez pas le savoir nous
n'étions pas là et et puis c'est très
intime
ça dit quelque chose comme ça de ce que
pensent et napoléon de ce que disait
napoléon ii comment napoléon est mort
l'empereur n'ouvre plus les yeux serait
plus qu'un cadavre
son gilet couvert de crachats rougeâtre
qui n'ont pas la force d'aller plus loin
on ouvre les rideaux les fenêtres du
billard de l'armée sortie de l'oeil
gauche ou quoi
du côté de l'oreille bertrand les suit
oh
napoléon la mort de l'aigle c'est ce
soir à 20 heures au conservatoire de
grandes n'hésitez pas il reste des
places
là où ça bouge au château de canaux pour
vous parler de restauration et de
patrimoine car ici les statuts du parc
sont malades elles ont besoin de vous
c'est que plein de mécènes même qui
donne une petite somme
en se regroupant autour du même
prochaine peuvent permettre de financer
la restauration les bus est pas qu voilà
même 27 ans si on les compte tout on a
réparti en deux tranches du coup parce
que c'est vrai que c'est assez important
et on espère qu'au bout du compte on va
pouvoir faire les travaux pour les
sauver
cent mille euros 1 nous espérer récolter
à peu près pour cette deuxième campagne
alors l'idée c'est vraiment vous
puissiez revenir profiter du lieu donc
si vous faites un don aux alentours de
10 20 euros vous aurez des petites
entrées vous pourrez revenir visiter les
jardins donc profiter des statuts à
partir de 30 euros vous aurez le sac que
statut du château actuellement comme moi
ça centre voilà je participe à la
restauration du château
tout à fait alors c'est une possible
d'artagnan surtout dépêchez-vous parce
que je crois qu'on a plus que jusqu'au
oui exactement 31 octobre pour aller
jusqu'aux 5000 euros donnés pour ses
statuts on va aller voir les autres la
voix près du château merci sabine
elles n'ont pas toujours la preuve avec
les fouteurs de joie vendredi agneau
pour est revenue dans les champs